Now I have, I do, I must tell you
that I have very bad news for you.
Oh God.
She said it has nothing to do with the
exams that I've been talking with my
economist friends.
And what they tell me is
that you are inferior goods
and they even tell me that Yale students
are probably among the most inferior of
all goods. So of course, you know,
put on my naive face and said,
what are you talking about?
And this is what I
learned. So you take, ah,
I hope I've learned to bring my
yes,
good.
This is standard economic kind of diagram.
And what it shows is the amount of
clothing that an individual buys and if
they're very poor,
they buy at the Salvation Army store
and they spend very little bit, or they,
they buy very few clothing
when they get rich. Oh,
they go to Brooks brothers and
buy suits for thousand dollars.
And that's probably an underestimate
of what they actually spend.
And so as their income increases,
the amount that they spend with a number
of things that they buy increases all
very standard kind of thing.
The ratio,
there's an extra little Phillip to this,
not wildly important for this course
is how much this line increases.
Uh, and for a particular change in
income is called the elasticity.
How,
how big a change there is.
And in clothing you really don't need
an awful lot of clothing had to go on.
Uh, so, but you can, you
know, spend a lot on it.
And I know myself that when
I was a graduate student,
I used to buy all my clothing at the
goodwill store and now that I'm professor
of a little more income and they don't
buy so much of the goodwill store,
but it's still a great place to my things.
And I see the other graduate,
the graduate students know exactly
what I'm talking about. They make,
clothing has a big, uh, elasticity,
but food down here,
you know,
you really can't eat that
much more food. Uh, you know,
we try of course, uh, but we don't
succeed. So no matter what your income is,
if you, uh, certainly if you
measure the food in pounds, uh,
you don't eat an awful lot more.
If you measured in dollars,
you can buy caviar and you know,
live on caviar,
but basically there can be a high
elasticy city or or low Alasta city.
Okay,
so that's one of the clear clearance.
Simple ideas that economics and I'm
sure it's nothing new to you now.
Can you think,
think of a counter example to this?
Something that as people get richer,
they buy less of
what?
Spam. Good. Cheap food.
What's a, what's a car that's,
that's a generation. Go Spam. How
many of you have ever eaten spam?
You went to prep school or something?
I have never eaten spam
but Mcdonald's hamburgers.
I wonder those kinds of things.
And for people in a
poor country like rice,
what do they go from what?
Yeah,
brown rice. Unpolished rice is what the
poor people eat or in India, millet.
And then when they get more money to
go to polish rice and they go to wheat,
that in all countries,
food is one of the important things that
you eat up higher on the food chain.
You change what you want to eat depending
on your income and you can eat less.
Of what you previously did.
A lot of public transportation is another
example of goods that you buy less of.
As you get richer, you
take you, you take it.
If you get Richard to take a taxi or
you have your own limousine and the show
forward and so forth if
you're really wealthy.
So all of these things do the
opposite, uh, thing to that.
Economists have a word for that
kind of a good and it is inferior.
Good.
Okay.
Now what's another example of that you
guys that one of the most robust uh,
phenomena in the world is this fact
that poor people have a lot of kids,
rich people have very few kids.
This works no matter how you spin it,
you can compare a poor country cause I
take any sub Saharan Africa country that,
that you want to a rich country
take any European American,
Japanese country that you like.
If this is income across countries
as they say, cross sectional, uh,
this is very, very true. If you
look within a country like pick,
pick any country,
the rich people tend to have fewer
children than the poor people.
And also you can spin it
a third way with time.
If you look at when a country was poor,
there'll be having a lot of children.
And then as they develop economic and
the get rich, they have fewer children.
So this is an absolutely
a robust kind of data.
One of them.
Yeah.
What have you measured?
Valued children by investment per child.
Ah, we're going to get
to that, that later,
that that's at the end of a
lot of intermediate stuff.
So, but this is the number
of children that you get.
It's not how much you're spending on them,
but the number of children that you have.
So you have these three different
ways that you can have a high slope,
a low slope, and the slope
can even turn down. Whoops,
whoops. Whoops. This is
some real data for, uh,
this is,
uh,
the total fertility rate and going from
one or even less up to eight children.
And this is the gross domestic product
per adult. And this is the log of it,
cause it goes over six orders
of magnitude. That's some,
some bases earn an awful lot.
Uh,
more so there's not a linear scale but,
but a log scale.
But over that whole range you can see
it's a very good correlation that uh,
those countries which have a poor income
have lot of children and those that
have a lot of income,
have few children.
And this is two different periods in time.
1960,
which is really before the third world
fertility transition in 2000 when you're
in the middle of the third world fertility
transition and you have these points
for the 1960,
the circles,
the pluses for 2000. And you see, there's,
what's happened is they've
slid down this line.
The countries have slid down this line.
There's still pretty much
the same relationship. Uh,
but uh,
the country's progressed in,
their income grows up. This
is the regression line, uh,
for this regression line for 1960.
This is the regression line for
2000 and small difference. Not,
it hasn't changed very much. So again,
this is really a very robust, uh,
kind of thing.
If you compare countries,
a 10% increase in per capita income
equates to a 13% decrease in fertility.
And it's a very interesting thing.
You have big cultural differences
between countries within a country where
you're under more or less,
if you have a homogeneous country,
more or less the same culture,
the,
the freedom of people to change
their for chill, to control,
to choose their fertility as much
more limited within a culture.
So now if you look only within a country,
you get a much smaller change,
a 10% increase in income correlates
with only a 1% change in fertility.
So it depends exactly how you run your
statistics, how big an effect this is.
But it's absolutely robust.
Uh, we always find it.
So here's a,
here's a great term paper for you,
or even a research paper
for the summer or something.
So it's usually this respect
to the Yale students.
It's usually presuming that the families
of the ELL students generally have a
very good income, probably
even within, I mean, we yell,
tries to get a distribution of incomes,
but within each class we
probably do very well.
So we're a high income group and it's
probably also true that we generally have
very few children, that your family's
probably each have very few children.
So you can take a ratio of a family income
to number of children and that ratio
for different groups. It's probably
a measure of how you are, right?
The higher the ratio income
to number of children, uh, uh,
tells you how much parents
don't want children because
they have a lot of income.
And guess who has this data?
Where have you filled in
this data admissions office?
If you're applying for a scholarship,
which I think at least three quarters
of you apparently do some sort of
financial aid,
uh,
they have income data on your family and
they also have the number of siblings
in your family.
All that is data that they have.
So if you can get it out of admissions,
you could really do some very interesting
study of what is that ratio for Yale
students. And then once it's
published from yell, everybody,
every other school in the
country is going to try to do it.
And it'll do for different works.
I haven't seen these kinds of things
published that this ratio for various
special socioeconomic groups.
Okay.
So this is kind of a
surprising, uh, uh, phenomenon,
uh, that, that, that, that rich
people buy have fewer children.
And
one year I taught this course
and there was a guy in it,
somewhat older guy who was actually
already a professor in Kenya,
but he'd come to Yale for more education.
They took this course and after the
course he told me that he was just blown
away,
that he had never realized coming from
Ken that that poor people had more
children than rich people actually put
it the other way. He had no idea that,
that one of the aspects of being
rich was that you have fewer,
fewer children using it. A
college professor, a university
professor in, in, in,
in Kenya. So this is quite,
uh, actually quite shocking.
Um, you heard, I mean, a whole cultural
story is that parents love children.
Parents want children while they
want them. Maybe they love them. Uh,
well not when they're teenagers of course.
Uh,
and so you'd expect that more income
would be an an an enabling factor,
very big enabling factor that you
in general have more children.
But it isn't the case.
Well this is anomalous.
Things are of great interest to
scientists including social scientists.
And so economists of course paid a
good amount of attention to this.
And the way they talk about children is
that they tried to general just the way
scientists try to generalize things, make
Newton's laws, applies to everything.
Whereas before there were
a lot of different things.
So they tried to use the same words they
use for suits, who food for children.
And the kinds of things they say are
that children are a time intensive
commodity. They take a
lot of, a lot of time to,
to either enjoy or bring
up, uh, properly. Uh,
women's value of time is a key component
in the price of children that children
have a price like any other,
uh, good, uh, the time this,
this all quotes out of recent articles,
the time cost of children and
other household production
children are one of the
things that households produce.
Then they talked about the opportunity
costs for households to produce and
consume a child. I loved
the idea that, well,
what parents are doing is consuming
you and I will put on the web,
uh, uh, an article by
Jonathan Swift, you know,
the same guy who did Gulliver's travels,
you know,
this article Amato's proposal.
Exactly. And what he,
and this is tongue in cheek in his part,
but at that time and much earlier,
much later, the English were concerned
about the Irish problem. There are shoe,
very poor. They had tons of kids and
they didn't like to be ruled by England.
Uh,
so the,
the Irish problem had to be solved in
what swift's suggested was that the Irish
eat their children and what this would do,
provide good food for them,
a lot of the protein and everything,
so it would solve their
starvation problem and reduce, uh,
the population problem there.
So of course this was tongue in cheek,
but it makes really interesting reading
and especially his notice his use of,
if you, if you bothered to read it, it's
not, not required. It's use of numbers.
It's full of numbers. It's a real
takeoff on what fairly contemporary.
And he has people like the people
starting to write a co economics. Uh,
we're writing. Okay. Uh,
so this idea that economics deals with
children just as they do with any other
commodity. It's, it's, it's the gene,
it's the genius of economics to be able
to do that just as the genius of science
to be able to make journalism.
But it's also one of the reasons
people reject the approach. They just,
people generally don't want to
consider themselves a commodities.
So why should people want fewer
children as, as they get richer? Well,
the basis of essentially all modern
economics is rational actor theory, uh,
that people act to maximize their
happiness or utility or preferences.
There's a lot of different jargon words
with slightly different meanings and
they don't act against
their self interests.
Now there's new psychological
economics or neuroeconomics,
which finds out this isn't really true,
but that doesn't matter.
Most theory depends on
rational actor theory.
And so they'd be kind of believe that
people decide what to do based on a
calculation.
It doesn't necessarily have to be a
conscious calculation which little problem
there of what's good for
them and they act that way.
So somehow economists have to figure
out why is it good for people who have
money to have fewer children,
what is in their self interest?
And actually, uh, a guy wrote a paper, uh,
Gary Becker in 1960 and then
he got a Nobel prize for this,
for bringing family when they go
family economics into the mainstream of
economics and treating
children like any other good.
And some of what I'm going to tell you,
it really comes from,
from Becker's theory. So, uh,
as I mentioned,
one of the fundamental ideas is that
it costs money to rear children.
And so they can be considered
an item to be purchased.
And so they call them a good, anything
that you purchased. This is called a good.
So children are, there's different kinds
of goods and children are all of them,
or at least most of them. One, there
are production good like a machine.
And production good is something like
you buy a machine for factory to do work.
And children, of course, especially in
poor settings, do various kinds of work.
We'll come back to each of these things.
Their consumption,
good consumption good is something
you buy and maybe eventually use up.
But you enjoy it.
You buy it because you get pleasure
in some sense out of having that,
not because it does work for you.
And the third thing is
they can be an investment.
Good that you put money into a child
when they're young and then when they're
older you get something
back for the return.
Just like putting money in a bond,
you put it in and then you wait some time
and you get, uh, presumably more back.
So first consider a children
as a production good,
which is very largely the case in,
in poor countries.
Uh,
uh,
one thing that's pretty obvious as
a child does not cost much to make.
It's pretty cheap. Uh,
and in a peasant family,
children do a lot of work for the family.
They can run errands,
they collect firewood, they can fetch
water, they take care of younger children,
they weed the fields. There's a whole
bunch of things that children will do.
And you read, you have some readings
on that in today's readings,
uh, and they actually do
a lot of work. Here's a,
here's an example of a little bars.
The name of the kid can run all over,
fetch up cows out of the stock fields
or oxen carrying stove wood in climbing
the corn crib and feed the hogs and
going errands down at his grandma's.
Guess where that description comes from?
Could be anywhere in the world.
It happens to be Kansas settler
in the late 18 hundreds.
So an American like other
places in the farm economy,
kids do an awful lot of work.
There's a saying from
Indonesia that by age seven,
a child does more work for the family
than the war family has to do for it.
So where,
so in to study that sociologists,
anthropologists and economists actually
go out in the field and observe in a
peasant societies and the professor
or a graduate student, uh,
stays with the family or stays very in
the same village with the family and
always carries around
a clipboard of these.
And what they do is they write down
everything that the parents do for the
children and everything that
the children do for the parents.
[inaudible] mom is cooking. Ah,
sister is washing vegetables.
Oh, little brother is sent
to the neighbors for a bit
of cooking oil. Oh baby.
Just defecated. Yup. Mom.
MOM stops cooking to clean up the baby,
etc. Etc.
You can imagine all this
down on a clipboard.
That's when a child is young. Uh, the
family puts a lot of work into the child.
As the child gets older,
they require less and less from the
family and they start doing more work for
the family. And so economists count,
you can calculate or anthropologists,
anybody can calculate a crossover age.
What is the age at which children do
more work for the family measured saying
ours. Then the family does
work, uh, for the children. Uh,
it's no longer quite as young as the
seven that the Indonesians talked about,
but modern calculations showed
something like at age 13,
children are doing more
work in an agrarian society.
Children doing more work for the family,
then the family puts in to them.
In your reading packet is
a story about ton of mom,
ton of mine money, uh, from Malaysia
and every year students don't.
Why did, it's a wonderful story. Your
love, why did, why did I put that in?
And of course it's child labor.
It shows you what,
how exactly a little bit unusual instance,
but how children are viewed
is not romantic at all.
It's a straight economic calculation.
You maximize the amount of work
that you get out of the child.
Jonathan swift and thinks mentions age
six as the age when children can begin
earning money as pickpockets and David
Copperfield was sent to work apparently
at the age of 10 and Charles Dickens
himself went to work at the age of 12.
Currently calculations from the uh,
United Nations International Labor
Organization shows that there's something
like 250 million children each five to
14 that are employed in half of these
children employed full time,
not as casual laborers but as full time.
And this estimate, this is not a
decreasing phenomenon, but, uh,
this estimate is up from earlier
ones of 73 million children.
So from 73 to a 250 million child
labor is apparently increasing quite
significantly in the world.
So an agrarian societies just
from the work that children do,
children can be an economic benefit.
And so people want a lot,
a lot of them to work around the farm.
And even in the early
stages of industrialization,
children are often sent, uh,
into earning work or they earn cash.
And,
and in real poverty situations in
industrially developing countries,
even the small wages of children
can make us sort of life and death,
life and death difference in
the survival of the family.
But notice that this all changes.
Now when modernization comes in, uh,
one thing to have the children go
to school and if they go to school,
they have fewer hours to work at home.
So their costs there,
their benefits goes down. Money has
to be provided for tuition, for books,
for clothing or uniforms
for shoes. Children on the
farm often don't have shoes,
but when they go into
the city to be proper,
they usually have to have shoes.
So their costs go up,
their benefit goes down,
their costs goes up.
Another aspect of monetization medicine
becomes available now for child gets
sick,
the parents have to spend money on doctors
are on medicine or they perceive that
they have to do such a thing
if,
if the families in the
city and previously,
and it gets to be a lot
of children working,
but they're also a lot
of adults out of work.
The government eventually puts in child
labor laws and says children can't work
and it makes it illegal
and therefore you can,
children can't work at all their benefit.
It goes down.
So all of these things act to reduce the
value of children as production goods.
They're just not as good a
production good as they used to be.
Now considered children as
a consumption. Good. Again,
that's the pleasure that uh,
or fulfillment that parents
get out of having children. Uh,
one article I read talks about
children as a consumer durable.
That's cause they last a long time
and they're like refrigerators.
They last a won't do either.
A durable good and you see the
reports every month or what, how do,
how many more of less Stewart
durable goods are being bought.
Um,
so it's very incent codes.
The purchase of durable goods you
don't usually pay cash for that.
They go into credit card and an easy
payment plan, uh, for later payment.
And it's the same for children.
They don't cost anything,
they don't cost much to make
and the costs come later.
I'm thinking of the child is kind
of like a house if you poor, uh,
or you can or could. And until the recent
debacle by House with no money down,
you don't have any,
any money and you get a mortgage and
it's later on after having the house that
you have to every year
pay off the mortgage,
you've got to maintain the house insurance
for the house taxes for the houses
that the upfront cost is
very small, uh, later.
And as you know, a lot of people,
uh, enjoy shopping very much.
And then once they choose,
they said, this is what I want.
They go to get to get a big bang
out of the actual purchase. And uh,
making children is very similar.
Uh,
people enjoy the foreplay
and then they get a big bang.
Well that didn't work very well.
Okay,
so another aspect finally. Got It. Uh,
another aspect of this is
children as consumption of goods.
And this has to do with modernization is
that you can't consider good separately
one from the other.
People have a certain amount of money
and what they buy will depend not only on
the cost of each individual good,
but on their relative costs.
And so what happens when
a country modernizes the
respect of children's at the
cost of children is perceived to
go up, that you education, health,
all these,
all these clothing,
all of these costs go up in inexorably
where at the same time the cost of
manufactured items goes down
or radio player, television,
any of the goodies that you
spend an awful lot of time with,
as time goes on, technology improves.
The cost of those goes down.
So modernization increases not
only the absolute cost of children,
but more,
even more intensely the relative
costs causes their costs go up,
costs of other things that
people want a go down. So, uh,
that's another cause why people might
want fewer children as time goes on.
Another aspect is the
time cost of children.
An important idea is that people
have not only in limited income,
which they can spend as they choose,
but also limit amount of time.
And we all use the phrase of spend
their time and economists take that as a
serious issue and they think that
time is spent in a rational manner.
Time can be used for, for
leisure time can be used, uh,
for parenting or if the person works,
time can be money,
it can be used to work and earn money
and each person has to balance where each
family has to balance these things.
Most of the time,
and I'll show you some data on this,
required for child rearing is
spent by the mother. In fact,
almost exclusively in most societies, the
mother does all basically all the work.
Um,
in the peasant society,
the mother does all the housework,
everything at home is
jointly done by the mother.
And this time is not valued at all.
Mostly in peasant cultures. Women's work
at home doesn't count. She may do the,
she and the children may go out into
the field to do an awful lot of work,
weeding and everything.
And also again,
culturally this usually
just doesn't count.
So women's time is not particularly
valued in traditional societies.
And in traditional time
she can't get a job,
so she's not going to be able to get
there, just no jobs available for her.
But then modernization comes in and
jobs available in the cash economy and
cashews, what people value. Cash
in an agrarian society is so rare,
so difficult to come by that that's what,
what is really a valued jobs become
available and in many de industrializing
situations,
you know,
and especially in the third world now
the first jobs that become available are
low skill jobs like sewing that almost
every country that enters into the modern
war has started.
It's in code industrial revolution
by selling jobs in factories,
Bangladesh, Indonesia, all over the
world. Sewing is the first kind of thing.
And this is largely women's job and you
see this in China all over the world
that some of the earliest jobs in the
modern sector are for women assembly.
You look at a of pictures of assembly
lines and almost saying electronic goods,
who's doing the assembly? Very
largely, uh, women are doing it.
Um,
so the once job opportunities
become available,
then you start,
you set up a competition between child
bearing and working childbearing.
The woman is at home,
she can't be out in the city working
and her time is spent taking care of the
children and therefore she doesn't earn
an income or she can have fewer children
or no children and go
to work and earn income.
So monitor what happens is
the opportunity cost to women,
which was considered essentially
zero in traditional times,
starts rising as jobs
become available for women,
the opportunity cost of
having children rises.
So that's another thing that
is modernization, uh, proceeds.
You might expect that families want
fewer children as modernization,
perceived people get richer and all of
these effects might really not be due to
the income, but just time going on, uh,
in the way that I've been been talking
about the changes that modernization
brings.
Now the third kind of thing
we have to consider, uh,
for children is to consider
them as an investment. Good.
That means you pay now
you get a return later.
And of course the value of children
doesn't stop once they grow up.
If the culture has strong families,
and that's a very important,
if then the children when they grow
up will perceive that they have a
responsibility toward the parents and
that they have responsibilities to support
the parents in old age
reason before old age.
It's interesting to note that if there's
no stock market in a country or banks
and poor people really don't have
access to these things in most places,
at the earliest stage of industrious,
there's nothing else for people to invest
in. There's just no market for things.
There's no market for their savings.
Uh,
because rats and insects
eat up an awful lot of food,
you can't really store the food. So, uh,
basically the, oh, almost the only
mode of investment is in children.
So children are indeed in a,
in premodern society is very
much an investment. Good.
And uh, this is brought home, I
mean, I read a lot about this,
but the experience of it in a developing
country, it's very interesting to hear.
So we had a graduate student,
he was from India and he was
from an upper class family. Uh,
and uh, that his family had only a
few children and all his relatives,
this whole class,
the people he really knew I had already
done their fertility transition,
had very few children,
but he was a good hearted soul and uh,
wanted to um,
help, uh, uh, poor people. So, um,
he worked before he came to Yale,
he worked in an adult literacy program
and that's really one of the best things
that you can do in this particular program
was aimed at the very poorest people
who are still illiterate.
And in the course they discussed
everything cause you need vocabulary,
you need to discuss it. So there's a
lot of discussion as well as reading.
And one of the things they discussed
was family planning. In fact,
a non had been speaking in class
strongly in favor of family planning,
trying to convince them that they
shouldn't have so many children,
that they would be better
off with fewer children,
which was the experience of
his social class. But one day,
one of the adults took it on
this guy aside to, you know,
you were wrong about family planning.
I have no money to save for retirement.
There's no social security.
The government won't
care for me in old age.
I need a son to care for me in old age.
I have 10 children.
If even one of them survives
and become successful,
then I'll be lucky and
have a comfortable old age.
So that was very nicely put what
the, what the man said to a non, uh,
but it's also a nice reaction. Was,
was also very interesting that uh,
even they grew up in India, had never
thought of that about that before.
He never heard about it.
He never thought that he never perceived
it from the point of view of a poor
pres. And he was very impressed. And,
and when he told me this story, uh,
what he said, he, he was, he was just a,
he was amazed at how compelling the
argument was and he couldn't think of
anything to say back to the person
in support of his previous views.
Uh,
so again of the very,
for the very poorest people about the
only strategy they have for old age is to
have children to take care of them.
And in most cultures that means
a son who will take care of them.
Kids cost very little in a
poverty stricken uh, culture. Uh,
they uh, they, they,
they were a hand me down clothes that
they don't have a toys or lots of any,
anything like that. They get basically
no school or medical care. Uh,
the kind of food that poor people eat
is fairly cheap and interesting in terms
of time beyond the first child. Uh,
if you have the first Saint John,
as soon as they get up
to be five, six, seven,
they start taking care
of the younger children.
So the time burden on the mother sort of
goes away once you have somewhat older
children and older means like five,
they can start scrapping the baby on
their back and going around with the baby
so that extra children are not, don't
even cost much time off for the parents,
they cost very little money. You already
have all the hand me down things.
So it's just a subsistence amount of,
of cheap food that the child needs.
So it's, it's uh, it's, it's, uh,
children are very small cost and their
benefit as old age insurance is perceived
to be quite,
quite great.
Okay. But what happens, uh, as,
as modernization.
So parents are basically willing,
poor parents who are willing to invest a
little bit that they have a little bit,
uh,
that's needed in a lot of children.
How does modernization
affect this investment?
If jobs start to be
available on the cities and,
or possibilities open up for
migration abroad to jobs?
All the people from India and Pakistan
that go to the Middle East to work in oil
related jobs as the rich economies.
There are people that come
to America to find jobs.
They all sent back. Remittances, at
least the first generation is very,
very good about sending back remittances,
which is a huge fraction of,
of poor people's income.
And even though the remittances may
not be a huge fraction of what they're
earning in America or in Saudi Arabia,
uh,
in terms of the income that they're
parents are living on poverty stricken,
it can be a very, very big
increment, uh, to their income.
And so children can be really good
investment if they can get up,
get a job in the city or
get a job, uh, abroad.
They are really good investment and
that's modernization increases everything
else.
It decreases the value of children.
But modernization increases their value
of this aspect of their value as an
investment.
Several other things happen
during modernization that
increased the value, uh,
investment. First of all, child mortality,
the first thing in the
demographic transition are
usually the first thing that
happens is of quite severe
drop in infant mortality.
And what that means is children now
likely to grow up that previously children
died very young or died,
uh, various times, uh,
in their, their young ages. And if
something is going to disappear,
like if somebody is going to
get stolen from you, you know,
you don't try to buy a really fancy car.
If you're pretty sure
it's going to get stolen.
And it's the same thing with children.
If the odds are very high
that your children are going
to die, it's really not.
And if the modern
medicine isn't available,
it's not really a good idea to put a
lot of investment into a child, uh,
that's going to,
you're going to die.
But as monitorization some ideas of
sanitation, public health come into play,
and the expectation that
children will live increases,
then there's a longer period for
them to live and return income, uh,
to the parents. The other side of
the coin is, is pretty much the same.
The parents are living longer. So, uh,
in the old style of fertility,
married people just kept having children
until they became a sterile at 45 or
something like that.
And then at the old life expectancy,
they didn't have much longer to live.
So,
and they were still capable of working at
40, 45, and then they, and they die. So,
uh, even if they have
children that stay alive,
there's not a long period of dependency
where they'll get income from their
children.
So if you have your last child,
it's a 40 or 45, uh, uh,
then they're going to reach maturity when
you're 60 or over something almost 60.
And that's, uh, at or above the,
the life expectancy in very
poor countries. So the,
the increased longevity of
both children and parents, uh,
make it a much better deal to have
children as an investment. Good.
Because as longer time they can pay you
and you're going to be around for longer
time to get this.
So as opposed to the other ways that,
that children are looked at
economically as an investment, good.
A modernization can massively
increase the value of children.
So that would be,
so we have counter balancing.
If people have more money
as modernization goes on,
you think they could afford more children,
but they become less good
as consumption goods.
They become less good as production goods,
but they come much better
as investment goods.
And of course as people have more money,
they have more money that they can save.
And one of the ways they save it
is by investing in the children.
So one of the issues then is, okay, if,
if the value of children is now
mostly as an investment, good.
How do you maximize,
uh,
this investment in agrarian societies?
They're really no opportunities
outside farming. That's,
that's what the society
does, period. We're done.
If in indeed the
agriculture is traditional,
you're doing it exactly the way your
grandfather did it and his grandfather did
it. And that's a very safe way
to farm because you're, you're,
you're on the edge of thrive. The Vir
crop doesn't grow, you're in big trouble.
So if you try something new, there's
always a danger that it might not work.
If you do something the way it's been
done for hundreds of years or thousands of
years, or you perceive as thousands
of years in your family, on your land,
you're pretty sure that
it's going to work.
You may not get an awful lot out of it,
but assure you it's going to work.
So peasants are very conservative,
not only about their,
their production,
their agricultural production,
but everything else in their
life because they don't have any,
anything extra to gamble,
gamble with.
So they're not going to take on anything
new. And the old way of doing it,
father passes it off to Sun.
Exactly has been doing it.
You don't need an education to do
farming in a traditional kind of way.
You learn it while doing,
uh, with your father.
Um,
so,
but when education gets
modernize, when, uh,
when agriculture gets modernized,
there's fertilizers,
there's new varieties of seeds.
You have to pay attention to money.
And when you enter into
the market economy,
you have to have some mathematical
abilities to know about money.
You may have to borrow money. This
interest rates, this payback schedules,
there's all kinds of things.
So that education starts becoming
very valuable even in agriculture.
And so early on,
the combination of not needing,
uh,
education and the propagated that
kids will die young invest with,
there's really not much benefit in
investing in education in an early
agricultural society.
Uh,
so the best strategy at that time is to
have a lot of children and put them in a
minimal investment,
in a minimal investment in each of them
and hope that some of them don't die.
And that's in fact empirically
true that the investment, uh,
before the for the demographic transition,
the investment that people
put into their children,
each shore was indeed very small and
subsistence carried on the way it always
was.
But now population increases cause,
uh,
foreign foods come in,
all kinds of things happen and,
and population starts increasing.
Land become scarce.
Now imagine you have a small farm and
you yourself are living as a subsistence
farmer and you've got a whole bunch of
kids and now you're faced with dividing
up your land among the
kids. Well, you know,
the kids aren't going to be able to do it.
You can barely do it on your size.
Farmers who divided up among two,
three or so sons,
it just ain't gonna work.
So you're in crisis. Uh,
and when the kids inherit session,
a little bit of land,
not only are they going to have big
trouble and then I can have any access to
provide for you.
So children's stopped becoming junior
if they stay in the farm economy,
stopped becoming any kind of
a decent investment, uh, to,
uh, to keep you going when you're,
when you're getting a little old.
So you've got to figure out what,
what to do.
You're facing the crisis,
but the outside economy is modernizing.
You may not be modernizing,
but the outside economy is modernizing
and jobs become available largely jobs
that requires some sort of education,
white collar jobs.
The government jobs are big,
huge bureaucracies spring up,
I'll mention that a little bit.
And uh,
parents rather rapidly realized that
the only option is for the kids to go to
the city and get a job. And,
but there's all the parents,
everybody reaches that state
pretty much the same time.
So the cities are just flooded with
people coming in looking for the still
scarce jobs.
How do you have an edge up?
It has to be education that the only way
you can get these are white collar jobs.
Absolutely need an education. In
manufacturing jobs, you do better.
You have to deal with machinery. You
have to know things about the machinery.
I was in Peru quite a ways back and
they took peasants off the Altiplano.
There's high dry playing with there's no
water and the land is terrible and they
live on about a dollar a day.
And in order to get a job in the mines,
the first job is you take a shovel
and you shove your, you know,
there's big machines that eat
away at the rock face and,
but a lot of it drops down in the,
uh,
people with shovels to get the rest
of it and dump it into the truck.
So this is really a minimum skill, labor
job. But they needed to have two things,
which not everyone had one.
To know that machines can be dangerous,
that they can get hot from
spinning around, that they
can be electrified. They do.
You don't just touch something
unless you know what's going on.
And the same thing, you have
to know enough about time
to get to the job on time.
Every day to shift comes on you. You've
got to be there and the peasants don't,
don't come knowing those sorts of things.
And those that do know those things.
Can, uh, uh,
double their income to like $2
a day if they can get jobs in.
So, uh, that's,
that's even the most basic kind of
job requires a kind of mindset and
educational thing that you
don't get a generally on a farm.
Um,
so education becomes an extremely
valuable, uh, commodity.
And uh,
so in order to get the job and to
stay live, kids have to be healthy.
So you also have to put,
you have to put money into education and
you have put money into health for the
kids. That's the projected
to have. If you have a,
you can have a bond like your kid,
you got to have a safe deposit box for it.
That's like health insurance or health
care for it and otherwise it's going to
disappear on you.
So this investment in children,
which in education, in
health care, uh, uh,
becomes a very good deal that if you
can manage to invest that much in your
child,
didn't go to the city or go abroad,
get a good job and their income
will be so much more than yours,
that they can send you
back a significant amount.
These investments with
children called human capital,
the result of them is
called human capital.
It's the health and
education of the population.
And it's now realized that when
the economists study, you know,
why is one country rich and one country
poor? Well, part of is their physical,
their stock of physical capital,
physical capital is the factories,
the machines, the buildings, all
the stuff that you come knock on.
But they realize that that's
not the biggest difference.
The biggest differences.
Human cat, what they call human capital,
how educated and how healthy, uh,
the population is.
So it's a very big
thing.
And so an interesting thing we have to,
uh,
different factors that are now in play.
Why a child becomes a good investment,
good one. With education, they
can get a higher paying job.
And with better health they can live
longer and the parents can live longer.
So they're paying you back not only at
a higher rate if they're educated and
healthy,
but for a longer time period.
So we normally think of the things they,
well you get a certain benefit, uh,
from uh,
their education earning more per,
per year and you get a certain
benefit from their health.
They're living longer and you
might be tended to add those too,
but in fact they multiply that you're
getting a certain extra amount per year
over 30 years or something like that.
So the two factors multiply and that's
one of the really big things in Becker's
theory is how these factors that go into
the income that a child will bring in
the health and the education
multiply with each other.
And so even fairly small increments
in either one, the to a very big,
uh, return multiplication
is a very large effect.
So the end, the end of
this, that as an investment,
good investment in children's health
and education is very rewarding.
It's a really rewarding kind of investment
in the kind of economic situation
that we've been discussing.
But here's the catch that if you're poor,
you can't make these investments in
a whole lot of a lot of children.
And so the best strategy,
instead of having a lot of children of
dividing up your assets among a bunch of
them, you have a very few children
and you concentrate your assets,
your concentrate,
what you can invest in a few children
and you get them fairly good healthcare
and as good an education
as you can get for it.
Children that have these two things, it's
called the quality of the child. Again,
that's another economic jargon term that
the health and education child are of
the quality of the child.
And the way this change that goes in
the demographic transition is called the
switch or the trade off from quantity
to quality before the transition.
Uh,
parents want a lot of children because
the main thing they're worried about is
the probability that
they're just going to die.
And there's nothing in the parents can do
about that. The local folk medicine is,
is almost totally ineffective.
So the kids are just going
to die kind of randomly.
But as time goes on, uh,
that's, that's not true anymore.
They can do something about it to keep
their kids alive and they get the kids
educated so that they can earn
a good rate of, of, of income.
And so they,
there's this trade of the switch from
wanting quantity to one in quality in the
children.
And parents catch onto this very quickly.
Some of the,
the very re rapidity of some of the third
world fertility declines has been due
to that. Uh, when the land
gets filled up, my people,
it becomes very obvious right away
that you've got to do something.
And the only job, the only thing available
jobs in the cities, and it's very,
they know very well that,
that the kids need education to,
to compete in that job market.
So in terms of policy,
you get some really
interesting kind of conundrums.
So one is education is what the
people want. They want it desperately.
And yet if they keep having
eight children, the country
is going to be hopeless.
So policymakers like the idea
that in order to get an education,
people have to reduce their,
their fertility, but they
also is with good hearts,
wanted to make education free.
So the question in a developing country
of how much to charge for education is,
is a very,
very major issue because you need to
strike a balance between allowing,
setting the price low enough so that you
can get a lot of your children educated
yet setting some price so that it's an
incentive to parents to not just absolute
flood the system and
overwhelmed, uh, everything.
And wherever you set this,
parents will always use strategies
to maximize their, their,
their benefit.
And one of the kinds of strategies that,
that people worry about that parents
can do is have the first child stays at
home.
Second child stays at home entry,
that child grows up and starts doing
work and then they can do the work around
the house that's needed in the weeding
the field and the work on the farm.
Your third child is now in a sense
surplus. You don't need their labor.
If there's free education, get them
educated, send them to the city.
And you can do that. If there's no cost
to getting a child educated third, fourth,
fifth, sixth, there's no limit to the
number of children that you can have.
You send them all off to the city, they
send you back money. Same with healthcare,
that if you have a a welfare government
and it doesn't set this just right.
If, if, uh, hell, if healthcare
is also a free or nearly free,
then again, there's no cost
to having the extra children.
People may continue to have that many
children and then the whole system just
gets flooded and you
have a failed experiment.
So education and healthcare are,
um,
some of the fundamental variables in this,
uh,
this religion between
economic development,
jobs becoming available and how
many children that you have.
And in developing countries, as you know,
there's a lot of people, labor is cheap,
but capital is scarce.
They're not rich. They,
they don't have a lot to invest
in factories and everything.
So it's hard for them to build a steel
plant or a petrochemical plant that takes
a lot of box in a lot of know how. But
what about, uh, producing a teacher?
Is that an expensive or cheap proposition?
Teaching is labor intensive.
It's not capital intensive.
You need maybe a chalkboard and some
chalk and some places don't even have have
that.
And so education is being labor
intensive is one of the cheap things that
countries can do.
So basically even the poorest
country can have a surplus labor law,
largely female and give it a minimal
amount of training or you have to do is
make them basically literate and they
can go out into the villages and teach
children to read and to write,
which is an amazing progress.
And then that bootstraps itself.
And if you look at at
developing countries,
that's one of the things
they really invest in is,
is his first primary education.
And they get a big return from that.
They're very,
they have the finances to do that.
And in fact,
almost all developing countries also
have a pretty good, uh, university,
uh,
structure,
not a research level university
but a teaching university.
So if you look at places
they're producing doctors, uh,
I don't know if you know this,
but in America,
something like half of all the doctors
that get licensed or trained abroad now,
some of them, England,
Sweden, Germany or you know,
train pretty much of the way we are, but
they're coming in from India, Pakistan,
Philippines,
places like that.
And the people just as smart as anywhere
else there, there may be work harder,
more and more ambitious. Maybe it's
harder even to get an to get into,
but they can train thousands and
thousands of doctors and you know,
a medical school class in Mexico City
will be like 3000 students or something.
The law classes are all very, very huge
because it's cheap and the, and the,
the marginal cost, if you're
ready, have a class in it,
in physiology with somebody lecturing
and another hundred students doesn't cost
you anything. So education
up to very high levels, uh,
is is something that,
that uh,
developing countries can often afford
because it's a labor intensive occupation.
And when you think of,
of, of the brain drain,
what happens then as you get more doctors
than India can support more doctors or
the Mexico can support.
So they want to come to the United States.
You get the brain drain that the most
highly educated people from all these
developing countries,
which the government has invested
in to to pay for their education.
They go to England, they go
to America, they go to France,
they go to Japan if they're
allowed in and they get a job.
So that's the old style brain drain where
the people physically moved to here.
But it's also the modern
job flight that now again,
as I said with the Internet and cheap
shipping costs or these jobs can stay in
India or somewhere. And we shipped
the jobs out the accounting.
So accounting is done in the daytime
banks to all the kinds of transactions.
They ship all that data overnight
to India. And during our night,
which is India's day,
the Indian accounts work on it.
And by the morning you have
all your accounts settled.
Engineering has worked on in
Chicago, uh, during the day.
And then however far the plans of God a
shipped off to you can usually India and
the, the, uh, the architects, their
work on it and shipped back to Chicago.
And that's increasing.
And so one of the important factors
in this is basically the cheapness of
education, that education,
labor intensive operation.
And so developing countries
can do it quite well,
but within the developing countries,
they can rather rapidly produce a lot of,
say, college educated people. And these
people expect good jobs. You know,
they've risen up by maybe by great
amount of effort risen up from,
from the utter poverty in their villages.
And now they have a college education and
they're ready for a job at the country,
usually doesn't have jobs for them.
The economies is not yet developed.
So what is,
there's a tremendous demand for BlueCat
for white color jobs and who and in,
and if they don't get
these white collar jobs,
they're tremendous unrest among the young
educated people. They're very verbal,
they know each other, they know
how to communicate. They're mobile.
You can have a very unstable
political situation up right away.
So the governments and all
the things almost always
respond with government jobs.
Since there isn't a private sector
is not yet capable of producing John,
there's government jobs and you'd get
these enormously bloated bureaucracies and
almost every, uh, underdeveloped country
where to do the tiniest little thing,
you need 16 different people to,
to stamp it and sign it and improving.
It takes three days for each of
these people to make a decision.
And so that's sort of things
get out of whack when,
because it's cheap.
You can produce a lot of education,
but then you can't get them jobs.
And then once you establish
these big bureaucracies,
then further economic development become
difficult because to do the slightest
thing, build a factory or do
something new or import something,
you have to go through
all this bureaucracy.
And because the government doesn't
have money pay these people, you know,
they get paid very poorly. So
corruption, they can, you know,
if you give us very small bribe,
this is,
this is a wonderful thing
for the bureaucrats.
So he'll pay attention to your thing
and only take two days instead of three
days to approve whatever it
is you've given him. So again,
this is the problems of the relationship
with demography and international and
economic development in poor countries.
It's all these interlocking things.
The demography always interlocks with
every other aspect of your economic
development.
Okay. So in terms of, uh,
the whole picture of,
of the change in the world,
probably this is the kind
of sequence does that,
we've talked a lot of different factors
that, that happened to bring people into,
into
modernity.
And so I want to sort of
summarize a lot of that. Um,
the first thing that apparently happens,
it starts in the renaissance in the
west and then continues on into,
and the enlightenment and
then the industrial evolution
is that the first thing
that happens is people start thinking
supernaturally about things and start
thinking about the real world and
trying to think rationally about it.
So technological progress and sewers
and allows them better shipping,
better navigation. They get all the way
to America, discover American foods,
bring them back and start a
population increase. Uh, in Europe,
uh, good ways to prevent
disease are discovered. Uh,
industrial revolution
increases productivity.
You start thinking rational about
things and everything can get better,
more food and it means less staff.
And so population increases and the
starts in the 17 hundreds in Europe and
really starts saying 19 hundreds in
the currently developing countries.
And we saw before that sometimes you know,
that the relationship between
mortality drop and fertility drop was,
was not a given. And,
but in almost all cases,
whether they went in parallel,
that mortality was below fertility.
So since early time population has been
increasing and even in a still agrarian
society,
that means is population increase,
the pressure on the land
is going to go up and uh,
you're, you're going to get
tinier and Tinier plots until
you reach a crisis. Now,
some places it remember what a
surprise we had that England,
which was an industrially advanced
as urbanization was advanced.
It's educational then
everything was advanced,
but it had one of the latest
fertility transitions. Why?
Maybe because of primogeniture that they
didn't have that kind of pressure on
the land because only the oldest son
inherited and the land plots did not get
smaller and smaller.
And the political structure was such that
the landed gentry gentry were the ones
that controlled parliament.
And the city's really didn't count
that much where the excess people were.
So England of France did not
experience the same kind of tiny,
entire pots and the vast amounts of
rural poverty that other places had.
So anyway, uh, with the scarcity of land,
the plots get smaller and
huge number in most places.
Huge numbers of people fall into
this abject kind of rural poverty.
And then two things that
I'm talking about today,
one or one of the things that I've
talked about today happens next for as
individual families have to
figure out a new strategy,
they realize that education for kids
is the only way out of of their their
situation and that means that they have
to have fewer children at the same time
with the spectrum,
they're currently developing countries,
the western governments,
either out of the goodness of their
heart or because they're scared about
revolution and communism and
anti-americanism, they have
to help the third world.
So they start supporting family planning
programs and what they do is two
things. One, they buy advertising
and just setting up Clements,
the the social,
the cultural acceptability of
controlling fertility by some sort of
contraception becomes acceptable.
It's not any more a totally taboo topic
and then they actually provide the goods
themselves,
so allows people to work there.
Their economic interest is in having
fewer children. But if their culture,
if there's not the contraceptives
available as say in China,
there was for a long time or
it's not cultural acceptable,
they can't act on that desire for
family planning programs committee,
the government ones are foreign
supported ones and you know,
their own government supported
ones or foreign ones towards once.
And that allows people to act on
their desires to have fewer children,
then fertility falls because they're
now using some sort of contraception.
Uh, and then as we saw, I guess,
La last lecture that when fertility falls,
then you get this bulge of workers
and then the economy takes off.
So that's kind of a way of
putting the whole thing together.
Now, this is all very nice theory
that I proposed to you. Uh,
and, uh, you noticed, or not too many
data slides that I put up for this.
It sounds great. I'm sure
you're all convinced yet
that's, that's a good answer.
When you started looking at
this, um, uh, in, in more detail,
uh,
things don't turn out to be so convincing.
Um, one about the cost of children, uh,
going up, which is the first part with
the children as a consumption. Good.
Well, what the children actually
need. They need some clothing,
they need some food, and it's
basically what they need to stay alive.
And that's all that they
got in the old days. Well,
what's happened to the price of
clothing in the last several decades?
No price or coding or wrong was fallen
tremendously. Clothing with a new fabric,
you can't wear it out. First
of all, I have that problem.
I can't throw things away. So my
clothes is just wrong. It's very cheap.
It's made in China, Bangladesh,
all around the world.
The price of clothing who has dropped
tremendously as a fraction of income, uh,
you always have to do it
as a fraction of income.
The price of food has dropped around
the world as a fraction of income.
So the basic necessities of children have
really dropped in price and drop quite
drastically. When you see a graph of
that, it, it's, it's quite drastic.
So if you consider the cost of providing
the same goods that pretends people
provided for the kids,
if two cost of providing that now has
gone way down as a fraction of income.
And as I said,
often it,
usually education is provided
free by the government and uh,
sometimes, uh, healthcare is
provided free by the government.
So,
uh,
it doesn't look like an economic issue
that if you want to just have kids the
way you're used to have them,
uh, the cost has not risen,
but the cost has gone down. But what
has changed is in the minds of people,
uh,
they now perceive that they must provide
for their children to completely expand
different than expanded set of
goods than, than previously. Uh,
children have to have the
kind of education that they,
that they never had before. They have
to have enrichment activities, uh,
all kinds of stuff. And if
you read about China, I mean,
it's amazing what Chinese,
they have only one child and
that child is so over programmed.
It makes you look lazy.
I mean they go to dancing lessons and
music lessons in English last at all
afterschool.
The kid is just working like crazy.
You may have noticed near the beginning
but not at the beginning of the previous,
like a whole bunch of Chinese
came in and sat over there.
They were the presidents of the student
nurse. I didn't know who they were.
They turned out to be the presidents of
the student associations and some of the
really big universities in
China. So these are, you know,
to get to be top dog and huge
university is a big, big deal.
And what were they interested
in this issue of modernization?
That they're spoiled.
They realize that they were telling me,
I spoke to them later that they
didn't want to have siblings.
They were really enjoying getting
everything as an only child.
They did not want a sibling.
She's laughing cause you know that story.
But also the other side of the coin is
as the only child they have to succeed,
they have to get top
grades in their education.
So the amount of pressure on them to
work like crazy all the time to study,
study, study, uh, is severe.
And they were interested in largely in
the pressures on them, which they were,
they were feeling guest as presidents of
the student bodies that are probably be
overachievers like crazy. And so they
would feel this pressure enormously.
And then your other stories where
kids learn to play this game.
So if a parent wants them,
oh,
why don't you wash the dishes tonight
or help around the house? Oh, if I do,
if I take time away from my studying,
I'll fail my course. So, uh,
it's this change in mentality,
uh,
that has raised the cost of childbearing.
It's not the actual that, that the,
the actual cost of child raising
if you raise them the old way,
that went way down. But there's been
a culture change that's required,
an enormous increase in the
expenditures on children.
And of course nowadays for you parents
don't expect probably anything from you
in return as, as an
investment. And you know,
just to pay one year of Yale is probably
more than some Chinese might make in
their whole life. Okay. Um,
now opportunity cost is
another interesting thing.
We talked about, uh, uh,
mother's time.
So it was his,
remember the cost of children is
not just what you spend in cash,
uh, but it's the opportunity
cost of childcare time.
And if you're out doing childcare,
you don't have the option
to also work at that.
And studies have shown that it's actually
the time cost of children that way
outweighs the, the, the, the direct
cost of buying things for them.
And 70% of the cost of a child is in
the value of the time spent on it.
So as people get richer,
yes,
they buy more for their children
and they buy more expensive things,
but their earning power
also rises. So, uh,
and it's this rise in earning
power that makes the 70%, uh, that,
so the 70% of the cost of children is at
the time they're not spending working.
But, um, when,
when the people go out and do
these times study things. Uh,
I don't know how well you can see this,
but this is the amount of time that
a mother spends in child care for her
children.
And there's one children,
it's 2.2 hours a day and even up to six
when they have five to six children,
the wife is not employed as a stay
at home mom. It's 1.9 there's,
there's really no,
no significant difference depending on
the number of children that you have.
This is upstate New York and then I
think the 1950s this is fairly recent.
This is not even a developing country.
The amount of time spent
is actually quite small.
Now compare this to the
mother getting a job. She's a,
so people were 40 hours a week.
Say if it's a nine to five and if they
don't get paid for the half hour of lunch
they can, it's like, I'm sorry.
They work eight hours a day and
depending on how you do lunch,
it can be eight and a half or nine hours
and then they have to commute and maybe
half an hour to work and half an hour
back was getting properly dressed for the,
for the job and commuting and
getting there. So we're talking nine,
10 hours a day that are
working mother in this case.
But it could be a father
is away from home.
So that's the cost of having
a job is like 10 hours.
The cost of having any number of children,
I mean it's seven to nine,
something different is going on and you
know, it's only about two hours a day.
So the cost in time of children
is not really all that great.
And the only time it gets bigger as if
the child is less than one year old,
which it takes three or four hours
a day to take care of the child. Uh,
now this is for all the members of
the family. This is just the mother.
This is all members of the
family. So again, now this
is 2.7. Compare that to two.
They have one child,
it's a half an hour.
The other members of the family together
put a half an hour into the child is
2.3 this is a little bigger,
but it's never more than an hour a day
put into the child for all of the other,
uh, uh, uh, things. And again,
it doesn't change an awful lot
with a lot of children later.
Children are cheap because there's
basic little incremental cost to that.
Here's more recent data and this,
the,
the red line here is mother's child care,
and this is per week,
not per day.
So it's something starts out
in the sixties and seventies,
which is comparable to the
data you just saw. It was nine,
10 hours a week, which is just a
little bit over an hour, a day.
And time goes on and I'll talk about
that later. It didn't, it increases,
but it's very small. And here's the
father's house work. It's like two,
two and a half hours a day.
So it's not,
so the amount of of time it
takes to deal with children,
although our myth is that it's very,
very time consuming.
And actual fact when you,
when you take the data,
it doesn't really work out that way.
And now you have be careful this is x,
this is extra time.
So this, uh, if you do house or this,
these numbers are extra time.
So even if you have no children,
take certain amount of time to, to take
care of a house. So that's, that's,
that's a fixed thing.
And then all of these numbers ask how
much extra time are you spending if you
have children. So compared to people
without children to people, children,
and of course that's the proper
number. Uh, without that we want,
um,
and
okay, so here is, um,
interesting thing.
So as this data gets more sophisticated,
you say,
well,
what does childcare mean when you can
take no children and compare it to people
with children. But if you
look at differently what the
mother is actually doing.
Sometimes it's her primary activity.
She's actually doing the child,
not really doing,
if anything else she's doing.
It's secondary like watching TV
or Washington or something. No,
that's primary and that's
an an hour and a half a day.
If it's primary or secondary.
So she may be what?
Washing the dishes or vacuuming and the
kid is right there and she's talking to
the kid and playing with a little bit.
It goes up a little bit and,
but it's still this,
this is pretty much the same number.
You seen the two previous slides,
so there's a couple of hours a day.
This is again per day and
the other slide was per week.
If you just count the time
there with the children at all,
you know they're linking both be watching
television together or they're not
really doing childcare that just
with the children it's still,
it gets to be more significant.
But this is not time taken away from
anything else that just a child happens to
be there
now and this is that this
is moderately stable.
It doesn't change between
65 and 98 about the same,
a little bit different
about about the same.
Now there's something interesting that
you might have missed in the slides.
I know we're going to stop in a minute.
Uh,
what's happens between 1965 and 1998 or
in the previous graph between 1965 and
2003 women go to work.
There's a huge difference in the number
of women, the fraction either the num,
both the number and the fraction of women
working between any of these ages and
yet what,
what do you see the amount of time that
the mother spends in Charlotte care goes
up from, you know, the
old during this period,
nine to 10 hours up to like 14 hours.
That as women go to work,
they spend more time with their children.
Part of the answer to that is this is
in the rest of house care non child.
How scared and with modern
gadgets and throw away stuff,
that amount has allowed women to
spend more time with children.
So again,
all this goes to contradict that part
of the economic theory that says that
childcare competes with working and
the evidence is very, very skinny. Uh,
uh, on that hypothesis. In fact,
if you ask your mothers were
any woman that has children,
what goes away when they go to work,
not childcare,
leisure time,
and sleep survey after survey says that
what women do differently when they work
as they get less sleep and
less leisure time. So, uh,
I guess that's all we can do today.
So see you Thursday.
We may not continue on this topic.
I think you get, get the idea.